In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 1st, on which we commemorate the Holy Apostle
Ananias.
On the first of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Apostle Ananias.
Each Ananias was a disciple of Christ living in Damascus three years after the ascension.
When the revelation on the road to Damascus left Paul blind from the overwhelming brilliance
of the divine light, it was Ananias who was sent to him.
He restored Paul's sight by the laying on of his hands and baptized him.
Later on Ananias was consecrated Bishop of Damascus by the Apostles.
Saint Ananias wrought many miracles in Damascus and Elothedopolis, by which a great number
of pagans were brought to the faith.
He became so well known that the authorities regarded him as a dangerous man.
The governor, Lucien, had him arrested and beaten with sinews of oxen.
They lacerated his chest and burnt his flesh with flaming torches.
Then, thrusting him outside the city walls, they stoned him and so saw to his departure
from this earthly dwelling place to the glorious assembly of the elect.
The prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.